I think charlie is claiming and again I  haven't heard the interview that he told  everyone in his life where we slept with  and stuff that he had HIV you youth when  did you learn that he had HIV right  along with everyone else he never said  anything to me  I was his girlfriend I lived with him  Roy were together we had sex almost  every day for a year  unprotected sex with lambskin condoms  which ER nada  no only pregnancy you were tweeted hate  I'm going right now and getting an HIV  test yeah have you told anyone the  results of that test no yeah you are the  first Howard I am negative I am negative  her HIV how long does it take to get the  result of an HIV test it was a 20-minute  wait and this is another thing I want to  bring up I had no idea that testing  centers like this were available but  it's absolutely free for anyone to go  and get HIV tested it 20 minutes the  test is free for everyone not just the  pantry sleep with Charlie Sheen